marco e c'è una creatura orribile alla
tua sinistra come mai dunque io non ho
mai visto una roba così brutta idea allo
stesso tempo e ribrezzo e ribery brella
e non si capisce ragazzi il problema di
questi infermiera buongiorno io sono
aracnofobia questo lo sapete o rivela
anche io sono veramente aracnofobia
ragazzi orribile però una fase di amore
odio in questo momento non so se nella
vita reale non probabimente no cioè
infermiera carina cosa ci dici oggi
visto che in questa bellissima stanza
dove c'è il trasportato nello scorso
episodio siete entrati nel bunker di sgp
qui non troverete uscite solo morte
atroci sofferenze ah beh sicuramente non
trovavamo i cannoli
il vostro obiettivo è trovare le chiavi
nascoste ma fate attenzione a questi io
stessa nei luoghi più impensabili
preparatevi perché non sarà difficile
con queste zampe l'ha nascosto con quei
ragazzi che lo dico io
e così prenderò fa vj quasi quasi ti
abbraccia le guarda che non rivelerà
distanza puoi rimanere anche a distanza
stavolta siamo bellissimo io vedo il
primo scp attraverso la finestra che le
specifiche la bambina che non so come
sappiamo aspetta che controllo su
facebook ok le killer away ragazza che
stai veramente dura è perché dovremmo
controllare tutti i blocchi praticamente
no quindi qualsiasi cosa aspettano ri
perché dietro i quadri solitamente gli
impatti con i fanno gli scherzi quindi
come vedi quadri con la mano chi col
destro poi anche toglierli sistema io
l'ho tolto di un anno genovese dove un
evento euro facciamo si apre a no guarda
che può essere che la ventola sia una
certa quindi state attenti e aprite
qualsiasi ma qualsiasi cosa
la ragazza mente non è
non c'è nulla con aspetta questo
processo di byte altro con la porta è
aperta quindi chi se ne frega con
troviamo oltre c'è un vice di livello
no carta di livello 2 serve serve la
carte di livello 2 ragazzi cerchiamo la
proverei nascosta nel ragazzi venite qua
alla faccia troppo da colpevole l'ha
nascosta nel cesso ios o mericano la
parola visto che come le ho parlato se
no andiamo ragazzi si è spaccato il il
battere casillas per sé non anomalo
respinta
forse nel pavimento pickers pavimento
pavimento aspetta visto che si paga e
quella per la tratta sì sì subito sotto
lo zerbino mai era subito onori grano
facile che abbiamo fregata cp regalo
costanti serve tanto che non mi serve ai
ragazzi la prima la prima è andata non
so le successive però per la prima ci
siamo let's go by mamma mia cosa devo
fare io bruciati tantissimo ok
questo è il nostro caso ancora no ma
togliti tu sei tu dici non passaggio si
no ha sparato dentro di noi e lo giuro
ragazzi sto male ma è incredibile
matt damon a cui guarda un secondo che
qua c'è una stanza piena di orsacchiotti
che crisi ci sono questi questi qua sono
scp 1048 che sono i builder bear che
sono di tre di tre tipi il bilderberg a
b e c quello o quella davanti non fa
niente se vedi 71 tocchi lui sparisce
basso invece gli altri ti possono anche
attaccare nella dura scelta spetta sono
è vero niente non se la sono calcolata
la cosa
ed entro domani suonerà dentro
televisore costruire lo giuro
ragazzi ho trovata perfetto ok in questa
banca abbia avuto una fortuna
incredibile vedi vedi che mi attaccano
guarda quanti ce ne sono come sai come
vedere vuoi vedere march ma cosa stai
combinando nostro aiuto blindness sto
morendo sto massa muaro st moro allora
26 blind straccetto perché non vedi più
nulla ma mia ragazza ok aprì la porta
per sempre sono messe scippi mm 0481 il
48 mamma mi riguarda se vuoi ti faccio
un regalo guarda mi guarda cosa ti
regalo a tutto questo
nell'attesa livello 2 no non è il
capello il cartello per ricordarle non
avrò 507 però posso guardare io che
cos'è e da vedere se vuoi te lo dico se
no
1057 giusto viene tenuto in una vasca di
contenimento di vetro rinforzata alta 4
metri e uno squalo è una specie di pesce
qualcosa di paesi sei sicuro che questo
qui dovrebbe essere e non da da questo
che dovrebbe essere il pink flaminio pro
aprire non c'è niente ecco infatti
costruire uno squalo stavo scherzando
lasciassi fule una gas e se vogliamo la
chiave come trovava scusami scusami ti
apro grazie a regole come troviamo la
chiave è maestra ma che comunque c'era
scritto che era lo shark the absence
vediamo aspetto a circolare ma anche io
mi informa accendo google la gara
impossibile ragazzi tecnicamente se ne
utilizziamo la brocca in televisori per
ucciderli loro non ci attaccano non c'è
se ne fottiamo 1 non dovrebbero
attaccargli vuoi provare tutti guardano
barilari salice se c'è blocchi salivano
nova scusami ma tornata che non l'abbia
fatto niente io ti ho fatto niente
io comunque per raccontare una cosa
prima lori e su google ha scritto sc p
1057 nola 1507 la parte fatto che questi
ok io mi quadrava andare
allora mi vado a scrivere scusatemi
manco scrivere sono ancora in guarda
molto sui cattivi ti guarda noi noti ma
cosa hai pensato dai lo faccio tanto non
sono pietro mamma mia
qualche cosa ragazzi è orribile ma
perché una le vite shaun ragazzi ma se
stesso come sai perché questa pena era
l'anno a quelli delle delle piccole
elettriche ma veramente ti fa ma è bello
ma cosa vuol dire che per un tot di essi
è bellissimo una cosa ce l'ho fatta per
indietro no davvero
ecco la chiave di meno quattro e roberto
l'albero è dentro un altro incredibile
allora adesso dobbiamo fare una roba to
my sotto tu vai a distrarre la gente
vada è il retro ivory ora ora noi non
richiamare ce n'è una che va dentro
aiuta ok sapremo che poi vieni che è
successo
no mi se disco un pezzo talmente tanti
flamingo che lasciato il segno ma allora
siamo è riuscito a crescere il server
con tutti flamingo è crashato e siamo
rimasti consiglio almeno non so voi o 3
3 elementare
a chiavari livello 4 le bistecche è più
piccola piccozza basta poi non c'è più
posto nè io proseguiamo mancano aspetta
aspetta aspetta fermo
questi qui sono pericolosissimi si
chiamano nola fissato dai massimo e
adesso cosa succede che se ne va fuori
ma allora bueno
ti spiego queste queste eyeball qua se
le guardi intrappolano ok e hanno
intrappolato marco è praticamente se tu
non ci dirla esatto se tu ne uccide ti
danno un effetto che dopo un minuto dopo
tot secondi il loro respiro a dietro di
te ti tolgono metà vita
ventura bello e quindi io facciamo poi
io l'ho ucciso no march ma perché lucci
contro di me l'importante è che chi se
ne frega che li verso ok basta basta
basta perché adesso la prima prima no
qua serve la carta di livello 5
non parla veloci ecco lo trovate nella
storia lory ma in tre non è possibile
entrare che spero tanto ci espone la
porta del bunker o mio dio come si apre
sta roba un mese di mettere 54
chissà che non ci credo questa si chiama
si chiami non lo so comunque si sta
sopra è una piscina incredibile tutta
rossa sono un sacco di sgp dentro ma no
mio dio veloci perché sparo si fanno
parte che li c'e la cia la ces quella
con immagino credo le coordinate quello
quadrilogia ma cos'è sta roba
a questo qui uno scheletrino ragazzi
guardate il re per favore non buttatevi
giù
guarda la funzione a 100 loro aiuto il
nostro picchiato che ha posto c'è gente
qua no non posso sarà la tedeschina non
afosa che sta schiacciando sto
schiacciamo non va da bar cdentrato la
precedente la gara è pazzesca sta cosa a
me non va guarda lo senti realizzato
raga 4 sicura eccoli eccoli un cuore
ayachi male e ti devo farli fuori tutti
i live a rai ti faccio fuori ma per
fortuna secondi per fare quello che
dobbiamo fare che ai ragazzi
ok la prendevo nel legno prendiamo del
legno ma nobile sottolinea fuori
dobbiamo fra for its cp qua ma
continuano a suonare possono sfondare
continuamente positivo e grazie al lago
rosso questa piscina qui ma non possiamo
far fuori sto coso gigantesco prima è ok
viti in trappola occhio trafori e
massimo ottimo dobbiamo prendere le mie
raiola su bandi pendole le lepri se l'è
presa fanno diventare soler viveva anche
quanto mancante la casi con il controllo
di controllo e spalle di controlli
spalle il continuo io quando quando non
è più che i sali in sali che c'è quel
libro sarà baila book in quel svetta
fahmy leggere nei giorni dei cieli
infermiera ma come come ha fatto a
comparire lì non si sa cosa dice ok
leggi le gelate queste sono le
coordinate per la prossima sfida psv ha
visti sempre bellissima becco ero certo
che coordinava dove ayane ora basta
meglio rinunciare coordinate ma dove
a questo su coordinate mi sono solamente
di telefono ma è il numero di telefono
direi che possiamo andare nel professor
jasonni nelle coordinate che ci sta
dicendo perché ci collega non so che
cosa è per adesso concludiamo qua è
stato bellissimo vedere il bunker giuro
è tanto è sparato un altro tizio ragazzi
ci rivediamo al prossimo episodio dsc
picco marci e marco e
io spero di beccare infermiera in
condizioni migliori
dovrai senza di vita più sull'argomento
mi piace ai iscrivetevi al canale
cliccata anche la campanella che
derivano e notifiche siete neanche anche
l'eni march marketing e noi come sempre
ci vediamo allora bei ragazzi
[Musica]